uh on this album uh Too Short says that
he could teach a girl how to make money
with her pee hole
uh yes
yep that'll do it yeah
that's too short man yeah shouts out the
too short I'm not sure the pee holes
technically what makes the money I don't
know the anatomy that wasn't clear yeah
like what is
is it like above or you get that you get
that too short verse back you're like
yes this is right on no this is right
this is what I wanted this is exactly
what I wanted that's exactly what I
wanted I need yeah like I needed him to
talk that greasy ass [ __ ] he did yeah he
said uh he said shake that he said shake
that crack
shake that ass you got ax
yes he says Shake Your Ass [ __ ] shake
your ass crack yeah not even not even
not even not even the cheese just the
crack no the crack how do you shake the
crack
um but I think it's it's like the crack
and then everything is surrounding the
crack that's what she should shake
that's fair tracks are the crack yeah
and shout out to crack Brian Sampson
smoked it in the 80s and he's all right
he's all right he's decent he's all
right